ah c'est le bruit et tu es morte
c'est impossible tuer mais je m'appelle
jared ross
je n'ai pas parlé à un autre humain
depuis deux ans mélanie
strike
c'est le début d'une histoire d'amour
et cela peut vous paraître banale à un
détail près ceci est le futur et
l'humanité est pratiquement éteinte
nous avons été envahis par une autre
espèce
qui a éliminé nos esprits et pris
possession de nos cordes
mais certains d'entre nous continuent de
vitesse
celui-ci lui dit
thiam
presque tous les os sont brisés et ses
organes touchés
celle-ci envie de vivre
les êtres humains ne sont pas des autres
face ils ne sont pas comme les autres
espèces que nous avons envoyé
car ces motions sont puissantes
si sa volonté a survécu avec ses
souvenirs et résistera peut-être de
l'intérieur
ouais
ce n'est pas humain
on doit arrêter d'agir comme des humains
mais me manque tellement je ferais
n'importe quoi pour la récupérer je dois
savoir
est-ce que mélanie est toujours là